(ominous music)
(thump)
- This is your new home.
- Home.
(upbeat music)
♪ Uptown got it's hustlers ♪
♪ The bowery got it's bums ♪
♪ 42nd street got big Jim walker ♪
- All right, let's get to work.
♪ He's a pool shooting son of a gun ♪
♪ Yeah, he big and dumb
as a man can come ♪
(coughing)
♪ But he stronger than a country hoss ♪
(bong)
- Oh, Jesus.
- [Eleven] Ghost.
- Yeah, I see that.
- [Eleven] Halloween.
- Sure is but right now
it's breakfast, okay.
- [Eleven] Trick or treat.
- You wanna go trick or treating?
(dramatic music)
You know the rules.
- [Eleven] Yes.
- Yes, so you know the answer.
- [Eleven] No but I don't,
they wouldn't see me.
- Hey, I don't care, I
don't care all right.
You go out there, ghost
or not, it's a risk.
We don't take risks, all right.
They're stupid
and
- [Eleven] We're not stupid.
- Exactly.
I do wish she lived long enough for me
to remember calling her mother
and it would be so sweet to say mother.
- Do I have mother?
- Yeah, of course you have a mother.
You couldn't really be born without one.
- Where is she?
- She's not around anymore.
- Gone?
- Yeah.
I'm sorry about that kid.
You gonna see them soon.
And not just in that head of yours,
you gonna see them in real life.
I feel like I'm making
progress with these people.
- Friends don't lie.
- What?
- You say soon on day 21,
you say soon on day 205,
you now say soon on day 326.
- What is this, you like
counting the days now
like you're some kind of prisoner?
- When is soon?
- Soon is when it's not dangerous anymore.
- When?
- I don't know.
- On day 500?
- On day 600?
- I don't know.
- Day 700, on day 800.
I need to see him!
- Jesus!
I said I--
(shatters)
Ah shit!
Shit.
- Friends don't lie.
(whoosh)
(thump)
You promised.
I go and I never leave.
Nothing ever happens.
- Yeah nothing happens and you stay safe.
- You lie.
- I don't lie, I protect
and I feed and I teach.
And all I ask of you is that
you follow three simple rules.
Three rules and you know one,
you can't even do that.
- I hate you.
- Yeah well, I'm not too
crazy about you either.
You know why?
'Cause you're a brat, you
know what that word means?
How about that be your
word for the day, huh?
Brat, why don't we look it up?
B-R-A-T, brat.
(swoosh)
(whoosh)
Hey, what the hell is wrong with you?
(grunts)
Hey!
(whoosh)
(thump)
Hey!
(whoosh)
(thump)
Open this door!
Open the dam door!
You wanna go out in the world,
you better grow up.
Grow the hell up!
(screams)
(shatters)
(jingles)
(sobs)
So what, we're not just
gonna talk about it, huh?
- About what?
- Oh, I don't know.
I'm just curious you know
why all of a sudden you look
like some kinda MTV punk.
I should have been there.
I should never have lied
to you about your mom.
Or about when you can leave.
A lot of things I shouldn't have done.
I'm so sorry
for every thing.
I can be so,
so,
- Stupid.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
Stupid.
Just really stupid.
- I've been stupid too.
- I guess we broke our rule.
I don't hate it by the way
this whole
look.
Kinda cool.
- Bitchen.
- Okay, sure.
Bitchen.
(freakish roars)
Ah, shit!
(gun shots)
(clicks)
(squealing)
(gun shots)
(whoosh)
(grunts)
(background chatter of TV)
(creaking)
Hey!
(whoosh)
(thump)
Hey!
Three inch minimum.
Leave the door open
(thump)
three inches.
(rattle)
El.
(thumps)
Open this door,
open the--
- What's wrong?
- No overcharge.
- I know little kid, I know.
- I can fight.
- Better than any of us.
But right now, I need you safe.
This thing is after you.
It's not after me.
Do you understand?
Hey.
I need you to understand.
- It's the speech, Hopper
wrote for you and Mike.
- Speech?
- Yeah, you know the heart to heart.
He never talked to you did he?
(rustling)
- Can I read?
- [Hopper Voiceover]
Something I've been wanting
to talk to you both about.
I know this is a difficult conversation
but I care about you both very much.
And I know that you care
about each other very much
and that's why it's important that we set
these boundaries moving forward
so we can build an environment
where we all feel comfortable,
trusted and open
to sharing our feelings.
Feelings.
(clicks)
(thump)
Feelings.
Jesus.
The truth is
for so long I've forgotten
what those even were.
I've been stuck in one place,
in a cave you might say.
A deep, dark cave.
And then I left some
Eggo's out in the woods
and you came into my whole life
and for the first time
in a long time,
I started to feel things again.
I started to feel happy
but lately, I guess I've been feeling
distant from you
like you're going away
from me or something.
I miss playing board games every night,
making triple-decker Eggo
extravaganzas at sunrise,
watching Westerns together
before we dose off
but I know you're getting older.
Growing,
changing
and I guess
if I'm being really honest
that's what scares me.
I don't want things to change
so I think maybe that's why I came in here
to try to maybe stop that change,
to turn back the clock
to make things go
back to how they were.
(deep breath)
But I know that's naive,
it's just not how life works
it's moving,
always moving whether you like it or not.
And yeah, sometimes it's painful,
sometimes it's sad
and sometimes it's surprising,
happy.
So you know what,
keep on growing up kid,
don't let me stop you.
Make mistakes, learn from them
and when life hurts you
because it will,
remember the hurt.
The hurt is good,
it means you're out of that cave
but please
if you don't mind,
for the sake of your poor old dad,
keep the door open three inches.
(laughs)
(sobs)
♪ I won't be king ♪
(knocking)
- Are you okay?
- Yeah.
(sobs)
Time to go?
- Yeah.
- I'll be out in a minute.
(sniffs)
♪ Or we could be heroes ♪
♪ Just for a day ♪
♪ Or we can be us ♪
♪ Just for one day ♪